il leur avait fait passer un grand oral
il va maintenant les noter peut-être
même sévèrement nicolas hulot appel aux
nombreux candidats à la présidentielle
les candidats qui ont signé son pacte
écologique que le développement durable
ne doit pas disparaître de la campagne
pourtant selon lui c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer
bénédicte doré nicolas hulot nommé
conseiller par josé manuel barosso sur
les questions de climat et d'énergie
voilà une reconnaissance européenne
bienvenue car en france
un mois après la signature du pacte
écologique il semblerait que l'écologie
est disparu des programmes électoraux
je suis juste étonnée que compte tenu de
ce qu'ils ont signé cette préoccupation
cette réflexion cet enjeu soit diluée au
point quasiment de disparaître dans
toutes leurs interventions publiques
il ya une forme d'incohérence qui mérite
interrogations
pourtant le 31 janvier dernier droite et
gauche se sont empressés de ratifier ce
fameux pacte à l'époque nicolas hulot
était crédité de 12% des votes devant
ségolène royal par la d'engagement à
l'excellence environnementale
nicolas sarkozy a même réclamé un g20 du
climat mais depuis plus un mot d'où la
colère de nicolas hulot
colère aussi des candidats écolos qui
l'accusent de décrédibiliser l'écologie
la conséquence de ce qu'il a fait en
faisant signer à tout le monde quelque
chose de très light c'est de tuer
carrément l'écologie politique en france
et avec cette attitude de surcroît de
relatif mépris à l'égard des candidats
qui défendent l'environnement depuis 25
ans comme moi même
eh bien il a accrédité l'idée que
finalement seuls comptaient les grands
partis mais les grands partis se foutent
de l'environnement on le savait avant et
on le sait après fait que les états
majors des partis est considéré qu'ils
étaient quittes avec ce sujet qui peut
passer à autre chose et servir tour à
tour d'autres clientèles qui leur
demandait le contraire des engagements
qu'ils avaient pris ne me paraît pas
dans le bon sens
les candidats signataires
encore quelques semaines pour rectifier
le tir d'ici là l'animateur de
télévision reviendra sur le terrain au
moins médiatique
il a convoqué les associations
écologiques un grand rassemblement
parisien le 1er avril